salut tout le monde c'est envergure
podcast spécialisé dans les jeunes
talents du basketball on parle on se
projette sur la draft de 2023 de la NBA
qui va être sélectionné dans les Top 20
top 30 on vous présente les différents
profils on vous donne l'essentiel sur
chacun des des prospects puisque c'est
comme ça qu'on appelle les jeunes en
vingtaine de minutes aujourd'hui
l'essentiel sur Brendon Miller
[Musique]
Brandon Miller né le 22 novembre 2002 il
aura 21 ans cette année de mettre 6 91
kg de mètres 10 de envergure nous
l'avons numéro 3 sur un autre big board
également numéro 3 chez ZI athlétique
numéro 2 même en termes de valeur
puisque c'est ne prends pas en compte
l'équipe qui draft numéro 2 chez ispn et
chez the Ringer également
pour parler de Brandon Miller Hugh est
là salut salut
bonsoir bonjour à toutes et à tous et
Manuela bonjour bonsoir salut Manu on va
commencer par la biographie de Brendan
Miller et c'est Hugues qui s'en charge
vamos
[Musique]
2002 qui a grandi dans le Tennessee il y
a quelque chose en lui de Tennessee il a
fait son lycée là-bas il a été élu
gâteau être plié de l'année dans le
Tennessee Mister basketball dans le
Tennessee et il a été recruté dans sa
carnatale puisque il a un membre de sa
famille alors un cousin ou un oncle faut
que je vérifie ça son cousin qui est le
coach de tennis state donc sombre
programme et puis la résisté à l'appel
de la famille il a trahi le frère de son
frère pour finalement partir à Alabama
alors Alabama c'est la loi matière de
son papa qui a été joueur de football
américain pour pour cet université il
était attendu enfin c'était un top 15
ispn finalement il leur a fait une
saison bien au-delà des attentes qu'on
avait autour de lui et aujourd'hui on en
parle effectivement comme un top 5 top 6
de draft oui et même un top 5 assuré
quasiment personne qui en parle en
dehors du top 5 en tout cas et
au niveau de
son père il s'était un tight hand pour
ceux qui connaissent le foot US il me
semble que c'est les costauds qui
finissent ces actions moi j'y connais
rien
quel rôle avait Brandon Miller à Alabama
je précise que nous on l'avait quand
même un top 10 tel après saison n'était
pas un peu plus haut que les autres et
il est monté également et il a profité
de la chute aussi d'autres prospects on
pense aux jumeaux Thompson qui a
beaucoup de questions autour de nortime
élite
et autour de leur shoot on pense à
d'autres freshman qui ont déçu les Nick
Smith qui ont été George etc qui était
projeté devant lui donc lui il n'a pas
déçu et même au contraire il a plutôt
brillé cette saison qu'est-ce qu'il
faisait à Alabama qu'est-ce qu'il avait
comme rôle offensif et défensif Manu
surtout un catch and shooter c'est
vraiment ça moi qui m'a marqué sur sa
saison c'est c'est du tir que du sur du
attraper shooté beaucoup moins de
création pour lui
ce qui est assez étonnant vu le gabarit
qu'il a c'est un vrai corps ça peut
bizarre de parler comme ça mais il a un
vrai corps pour du basket et c'est ça a
été une beaucoup de ça et uniquement sur
du 3 points aussi où là vous l'avez très
très peu de
dinde d'opportunité d'y aller parce que
c'est pas sa force première d'attaquer
le cercle et le jeu d'Alabama est fait
de trois points c'est vraiment ça aussi
la clé du truc et c'est beaucoup
beaucoup de ça très peu de création pour
lui ou pour les autres c'est pas lui qui
avait la balle du tout lui terminait les
actions
même s'il avait un taux d'usage assez je
trouve ouais on l'a vu dans des matchs
quand même avoir le ballon mais c'est
vrai que la plupart de la plus de la
moitié de ces tiers viennent à trois
points et viennent d'une passe décisive
mais quand il va au Cercle ça vient pas
forcément d'une passe décisive puis là
quand même combien de matchs
plus de 4 tirs par match au Cercle donc
il sait y aller quoi il est grand ouais
puis il finit assez bien il a 58% de
réussite
près du cercle donc c'est vraiment
intéressant et défensivement
des fossivement moi je l'ai trouvé assez
honnête sans sans plus un gars qui est
vraiment à
agressif dans le bon sens du terme en
fait il a beaucoup d'initiative
là-dessus et il est assez polyvalent
rapide bonne la télé-réalité et sur la
polyvalence
il défendait un peu sur sur les deux
trois quatre en NBA j'ai un peu plus de
mal à le projeter sur ces trois postes
là où je pense plus qu'il sera sur du 2
on voit léger ouais
s'il y a du Small Ball ou tu vois selon
les l'adversité à tel moment
pour l'instant c'est ça donc j'attends
un peu de voir
sur sur ça c'est peut-être une
questionnement aujourd'hui ça sa
projection défensive
il est projeté top 5 et même top 3
savez-vous qui est le dernier joueur à
avoir été drafté top 3
dans l'année de ces 21 ans puisque
Brandon Miller aura ses 21 ans cette
année sa date de 2013
[Musique]
c'est pour vous dire que c'est pas
courant c'est pour expliquer quand même
que c'est pas courant même si c'était sa
première saison NCA et ben il est
vachement vieux par rapport à
l'expérience qui leur fait il a l'âge
d'un junior ouais
c'est à dire un troisième année Hugues
pourquoi pourquoi il est projeté Sioux
pourquoi on pourquoi on draft Brandon
Miller quand on est un gmnba qu'est-ce
qu'on aime chez lui
encore une fois comme beaucoup de gens
dont on va parler cette année du spacing
effectivement il apporte un très beau
combo taille tire sur un poste où on va
pouvoir l'ordre du pick and pop que ce
soit lui qui pose l'écran voir même du
pouvoir poser le ballon et tirer c'est
pas quand même mec il fait beaucoup
chrétien de foot mais c'est pas qu'un
mec dans le projet de faire que ça on le
voit vraiment être un créateur balle en
main capable de se créer son propre tir
avoir du développement sur le comment
dire sur son drive d'avoir du
développement dans sa création de son
accès au cercle et du poulet mi distance
je pense que les gens qui croient voient
une sorte de Jason Tatum dans le dans le
profil physique et dans la potentialité
et c'est pour ça qu'il est attendu très
haut et sachant au plus mauvais scénario
tu auras un gars de
plus de 2,5 de mètres 6 qui pourra être
à 40% aujourd'hui facilement oui donc
c'est quand même c'est quand même énorme
c'est rare en fait de shooter si bien et
avec tant de fluidité à cette taille là
donc c'est vrai que c'est ça qu'on aime
chez lui est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
choses toi Manu qui te marque chez
Brandon Miller
qu'est-ce que tu penses Manu du du
développement si on draft ce joueur en
top 3 4 5
qu'est-ce qu'il faut lui faire
travailler en fait qu'est-ce qui peut
débloquer son potentiel
pour moi la clé ça va être ça sa
capacité à créer notamment pour lui
ou moi j'ai été assez déçu de ça sur sa
saison une sciais pour moi il y avait
trop de chance
mais pour moi pour qu'ils passent le
niveau supérieur et qui deviennent un
joueur encore plus élite de ce qui
peut-être déjà avec ce qu'il a c'est
vraiment ça la création d'espace la
création de tir pour lui et peut-être
aussi un peu con mais sera développé ce
son midrengame ouais
on le voit aujourd'hui notamment sur les
playoff ou les superstars développent le
développement de plus en plus et il
revient un peu à la mode c'est donc
ajouter ça donc c'est ouais
moi je sais en tête pour qu'ils
deviennent le joueur qui pense être
moi ce qui m'avait marqué je l'ai moins
vu jouer que vous je trouve que c'est un
joueur qui joue à son rythme qu'est-ce
que c'est à dire qu'il est jamais trop
speedé par la défense quand il a le
ballon
qu'est-ce que vous tu penses de son
undle Hugues et des choses qui doit
développer aussi même question que Manu
pour pour atteindre la valeur d'un top 3
en fait
je pense que son modèle est un peu
sous-estimé parce qu'il a pris beaucoup
de tirs l'an dernier on a déjà bah Will
Smith qui est pris top 3 alors sur un
profil plus plus intérieur mais
finalement ils ont pas un écart de
taille si grand et moins de 1000 ans
crée quand même beaucoup plus d'espace
pour lui il a un très bon changement de
direction et quand je parlais de TNT
c'est pas dans les fondamentaux dans la
fixation mais c'est vraiment cette
capacité à j'ai la balle main droite
j'arrive à partir ma gauche revenir à
main droite et ensuite enclencher sur un
step back donc il y a une vraie une
vraie polyvalence là dessus il peut
passer la balle devant il peut passer la
balle derrière il est capable de changer
de vitesse je trouve ça main forte un
peu plus en difficulté sur sa main
faible pour terminer au panier pour le
moment il y a pas la capacité à terminer
main faible près du cercle on a quand
même une main dominante droite pour pour
la finition donc ça va être vraiment cet
axe de développement mais j'y crois
assez je sais pas s'il aura énormément
d'efficacité sur les premières années
là-dessus sachant que comme tu l'as dit
il est déjà assez vieux donc
physiquement il devrait devrait être
peut-être un peu plus loin
mais je
j'étais assez surpris quand je regardais
pas mal de matchs où il avait été en
difficulté à sa capacité à prendre les
choses en main et à pouvoir se créer cet
écart là et donc je l'ai un peu monté au
fur et à mesure au début je m'étais dit
on avait ce débat sur le groupe on
disait que la différence entre lui et
jet Word par exemple est-ce qu'il y
avait vraiment un si gros écart que ça
pour moi l'écart il va se faire là dans
dans le dribble dans le changement de
main dans le création d'espace dans son
step back et dans cette mentalité qui là
reste cet objectif qu'il a lui d'être ce
jour-là donc voilà pour moi c'est ça le
ce qui fait qui passe de fin de
l'Autriche fin de Top 10 à Top 5 de
draft oui parce qu'elles fantasme du
joueur de plus de 2 mètres 3 4 qui peut
se corriger
se créer ses propres tirs quoi c'est à
dire les joueurs qui gagnent les
playoffs en gros même si cette année
c'est pas forcément comme quoi
est-ce que son manus c'est que tu aimes
bien regarder le potentiel la vision du
jeu etc je vois un
assisto donc le il a plus de te bal
perdu que de de passe décisive cette
année est-ce que c'est mérité ou est-ce
que ça cache un petit peu potentiel
je sais pas moi je l'ai pas trouvé pour
les autres en fait je l'ai vu un peu
remonter initié mais vraiment le des
prémices mais c'était pas trop trop vu
où c'est des c'est des passes de l'Aube
qui l'a fait et j'ai pas de sous j'ai
pas de souvenir de
flash qui qui met marqué
là-dessus ouais c'est parce qu'on lui
demandait trop quoi aussi ok
psychologiquement
on va rentrer dans le dur peut-être
déjà sur l'attitude terrain on passera
sur leur terrain après Manu qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que tu dis du joueur et
qu'est-ce que tu as entendu aussi des
dernières des interviews qu'il a pu
faire sont deux choses différentes mais
on va passer sur le côté psychologique
sur sa saison terrain moi j'ai pas vu de
choses qui m'ont choqué mais encore une
fois c'est difficile de à nous à notre
échelle face à un écran de de bien
savoir de bien visualiser les choses
disons qu'il peut y avoir des attitudes
au niveau de l'intensité de quand tu
rates un shoot tu baisse la tête tu
reviens pas en défense ce genre de
choses toi tu as pas vu de de drapeau
jaune on va dire sur ce côté là
maintenant on y repensant pas trop
moi j'en ai pas vu j'ai pas Hugues non
il est quand même assez caractériel
comme garçon je trouve que la première
image qu'on se fait lui c'est un gentil
garçon tu vois quand tu le vois une
première fois
et en fait pas vraiment alors je parle
pas forcément de genre terrain ou on va
y aller sur le bang bang Guy mais
il est très expressif il parle mal il
crache talk beaucoup dans son duel avec
Grégory Jackson face à face
il y avait il y avait un duel en début
de match
Bandon Miller il voilà il est agressif
défensivement il s'y met il s'implique
il se tape le torse il y va quoi donc
c'est un joueur qui monte du leadership
vocal entre guillemets je sais pas trop
et par contre
quand on a vu au tournoi de mars Madness
dans un contexte encore une fois très
spécifique après ce qui lui est arrivé
ce qui est ce qui s'est passé mais il
est entouré de vigile il avait reçu des
menaces de mort et tout ça et donc il a
fait un peu Cracotte un tonton Batman en
terme d'adresse et ça l'avait vraiment
impacté
c'est normal quand tu es aussi jeune et
que tu as pas connu ça et de tout ce qui
se passe mais voilà il y a eu une grosse
pression sur lui et il a craqué
disons que après le 21 février c'était
peut-être pas le même joueur donc je
vais raconter ce qui s'est passé et puis
vous pourrez réagir
donc quand je dis je vais raconter ce
qui s'est passé je ne sais pas si c'est
ce qui s'est passé mais en tout cas
c'est ce qu'il y a dans le rapport de
police qui a fuité puisque Brandon
Miller a amené
une arme à un endroit et cette arme a
servi à un homicide dans la foulée enfin
même un féminicide
Brandon Miller traînait avec un ancien
coéquipier donc pas des fréquentations
super apparemment
l'ancien coéquipier a oublié
son revolver enfin non je vois quel
genre de de flingue c'était mais dans la
voiture de Miller il lui a dit reviens
et amène amène le flingue il est revenu
il a récupéré le flingue et il a flingué
son ex voilà ce qui s'est passé
Brandon Miller n'est pas mise en examen
donc il est il est pas blanchi c'est à
dire qu'il est pas responsable c'est à
dire que il peut pas être condamné quoi
il est là en tant que témoin assisté
enfin c'est le l'équivalent de témoin
assisté
aux États-Unis
[Musique]
on en pense qu'on en veut c'est
évidemment la plus grosse question sur
Brandon Miller hors T1 et ce qui traîne
avec des gars qui vont qui vont lui
faire péter un plomb est-ce qu'il a une
mauvaise fréquentations en retard enfin
quand on voit ce qui se passe et moi
personnellement j'étais quand même assez
halluciné qu'on en parle pas plus
d'autant qu'il est projeté top 5 alors
que dans le même temps il y a l'ombre
d'un flingues sur une vidéo de James et
tout le monde je joue les vierge et
farouchés comme s'il y avait pas de
flingue qui circulaient aux États-Unis
donc
Brandon Miller s'en sort assez bien sur
le coup est-ce que vous pour vous ça le
pénalise dans votre classement je sais
pas où vous l'avez dans votre big board
d'ailleurs monsieur
ça me le pénalise pas tant que ça
sur ce qui s'est passé enfin l'affaire
est un peu un peu chelou sachant qu'au
début la menti à la police évidemment il
est revenu sur les faits etc et puis
derrière ça il y a ça célébration de
début de match où il flingue TF1 il fait
des des
pistolets
voilà il le fait toute la saison et puis
il a fait toute la saison donc c'est ça
et puis il y a une réaction c'est que
donc là la veille il se fait enfin la
faire sort le lendemain il y a un match
il fait son record en carrière en disant
ben moi j'en ai rien à faire de ce que
vous racontez en extérieur je suis là
pour jouer et il fait son meilleur match
au scoring en carrière donc ça montre
quand même aussi que qu'il assure qu'il
a su réagir là il a déclaré qu'il a fait
qu'il aurait fait le tri dans son
entourage aussi jeune c'est déjà assez
bizarre d'avoir un gang aussi développé
mais bon il y a un papa qui a l'air
quand même présent avec un passé sportif
il y a une famille qui galère assez uni
là-dessus il est encore jeune j'ai envie
de laisser le bénéfice du doute et de
toute façon les équipes feront leur
examens visuel tu vois on sait que le
chinois il y a Nico qui travaille
actuellement NBA je pense que voilà que
eux ils ont déjà des rapports
des rapports à ces développés sur boite
Miller et ils vont pouvoir fouiller ça
plus à prof enfin plus profondément que
nous
Manu toi qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça
t'évoque cette cette affaire est-ce que
tu l'as ou sur ton bord est-ce que tu la
descendu après ça ou pas non honnêtement
en faisant le bord j'ai même pas pensé
ce qui est assez fou
c'est vrai que c'est pas médiatique on
peut l'oublier
les articles on a fouiné on a mais ouais
tu vois je peux l'avoir 4
ou 5 je sais plus j'ai mon petit Walker
donc
j'y ai pas pensé mais
je pense que déjà ces arguments là sur
le combat une interviews combats
immédiat sont assez catastrophique
j'ai changé mon entourage j'ai fait des
trucs j'ai appris machin il peut pas
dire autre chose en même temps ouais
mais il peut aussi un peu mieux
s'expliquer je trouve que la façon dont
il le prime et
c'est pas fou ok tu as l'impression que
voilà on va pas se le cacher il est sûr
qu'il répondra à des questions là-dessus
sur oui donc
il a pas très bien révisé pour l'instant
ouais je sais pas ce qui a fait son
équipe de com mais
[Musique]
je sais pas soit un peu plus convaincant
parce que après de ce qu'on a appris
aussi de personnes aux États-Unis qui
suivent le process c'est que ces
interviews avec les équipes se sont
aussi très mal passées donc
c'est assez étonnant je pense que
l'affaire peut lui faire du mal
honnêtement ça ressemble à un personne
qui est assez influençable il faut voir
le faut voir le mental faut les scouts
ont évidemment creusé le le passé
familial le passé amical le passé tout
ce que vous voulez pour en savoir un peu
plus mais s'il est aussi haut dans
toutes les mocks américaines
c'est peut-être aussi que le retour sont
pas si catastrophiques que ça
absolument ou peut-être qu'il va
descendre ensuite en tout cas
il est clair que l'équipe qui draft et
l'opinion que cette équipe a de cette
incidence de cet incident de ce meurtre
pardon
aura des conséquences sur le fait qu'il
sera choisi deuxième troisième
visiblement ça serait difficile qui
descende plus de enfin au-delà de 5 6
selon une espion selon Jonathan
givonique quand même relativement bien
informé en tout cas par rapport à nous
est-ce que vous avez des choses à
ajouter sur brand Miller Hugues
peut-être sur le ce qu'on va lui faire
faire l'année prochaine en quelques mots
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qu'on devrait
lui faire faire l'année prochaine pour
pour qu'il atteigne pour qu'il se
développe encore
il va tomber quasi forcément dans une
équipe où il y aura un très fort porteur
de balle je regarde là le en gros on
parle du top 5 alors on sait que le top
1 bah c'est Victor donc ensuite derrière
la mélo en meneur de jeu si tu vas en
net c'est pas c'est pas dégueulasse en
terme de base les Blazers alors on sait
pas c'est bizarre quand on pique mais tu
peux avoir des milliards les requêtes
sont peut-être un peu plus énigmatiques
et les piston c'était quelques ningham
donc je pense pas qu'il aura trop de
pression balle en main la première année
pour les créations je pense qu'on va
peut-être le développer en tant que
deuxième
option au scoring et c'est
potentiellement la meilleure des choses
qui peut lui arriver
de la finition au début et puis des
répétitions des gammes du pain de la
création individuelle au fur et à mesure
pour arriver en année 3 4 5 sur un sur
un joueur potentiel All-Star est lié à
le monde comme l'étatum comme les
bonhommes etc donc voilà je pense que
l'année et le roadster du top du top 10
enfin il y a du top 6 et vraiment
ouais vraiment positif pour un bonhomme
de 1000 heures
je quant à dit les équipes je me suis
dit des trois ça leur ferait du
bien
juste dans le jeu quoi parce qu'ils ont
peut-être
assez de joueurs qui sont pas assez
concentrésors qu'ils ont fait un peu le
ménage mais bref est-ce que vous y
croyez oui non en un mot et en argument
je mets le dramatique piano
je crois pas mais je crois en 12 ans de
NBA et ça s'est déjà pas mal
c'était l'essentiel sur Brandon Miller
le projet du top five speak de cette
draft 2023 de la NBA venu d'Alabama
allez lire ce qu'on a écrit sur lui sur
envergure.co allez voir nos émissions et
réécouter nos autres podcasts sur
Youtube on vous fait des bisous Ciao